we talked to the health secretary matt
hancock about the uk's borders amid
reports the government could tighten
rules for
arrivals from abroad it's something
labour's shadow home secretary nick
thomas simmons has some opinions on
and he joins us now from south wales
good to see you what should happen when
when it comes to border control do you
think
well good morning stephen and obviously
please do pass my best wishes to sophie
for a swift
recovery nobody could say
that the situation at our borders is
satisfactory or that there is sufficient
protection in place for our people
against the different strains that could
be coming from around the world
so we need now to put additional
protections
in place we do need that effective
border testing regime
we also need an effective quarantining
regime which we've not
had the government did not
introduce a comprehensive quarantining
regime until june last year this
government was an
international outlier if you go back to
may last year
it was only the uk iran luxembourg and
the u.s virgin islands that had no
travel protections in place
it was too slow it was put into place in
june it isn't effective at the moment
we need that additional quarantining
protection
in place i would support for example the
introduction of the use of hotels
but above all we need a comprehensive
system and plan from the government
and stop moving from one chaotic
situation to another well hotels i mean
it's been it's been talked about before
and other countries are doing it are you
saying that everyone who arrives in the
uk
should be put into a hotel and forcibly
quarantined for
i don't know what would it be 10 10 days
or so
it does need to be a comprehensive
system clearly you would have to have
a very different system for hauliers for
lorries crossing the english channel
that would have to be obviously very
different
but in terms of uh travelers uh arriving
in the united kingdom you would need to
have that comprehensive system
let me just say why this is so important
because the government introduced
a quarantining system far too slowly in
june of last year
the government's own figures show that
between june of last year
and september around about two million
people
had their passenger locator forms their
details if you like
spot checked by border force at the
border
only around three percent of those were
successfully contacted to ensure they
were quarantined now that just
isn't good enough it isn't effective the
government hasn't had a grip on this
situation throughout
we desperately need them to get a grip
and have that comprehensive plan in
place i mean
even the meeting tomorrow and tuesday
that they're talking about having
should have happened on thursday even
that is too slow
this can't continue they need to have
that meeting
but forgive me it's all well and good to
talk about having a comprehensive
system in place and on the surface a lot
of people would agree with it but it's
all about the nuts and bolts
isn't it it's about what that system
actually is and
how you implement it back back to that
dreaded word
of logistics which is going to be
problematic with this so what exactly
would you do if you were in government
well the labour government would have
taken a very
different approach to the setup of the
quarantining system in the first place
the government's isolation assurance
service decided to
outsource this system to a company
called
sitl the government's own target of
contacting
20 of those coming into the united
kingdom hasn't been
met i mean i indicated the figures in my
last answer it's nowhere near that
so we would actually have used a far
more effective
system wouldn't have outsourced it in
the way that the government has
and we would have acted more quickly
i've been raising the issue of border
protections
from last april in april in june in
september
time and time again i've been raising
this issue
and the government has been but forgive
me forgive me
i mean we are where we are today
on the 24th of january so what would you
do moving forward
it's no good deciding what we what you
would have done it's what what would you
do from here on in
well i think the government does now
need to introduce quarantining hotels as
i've
already indicated the government also
then
needs to have that effective testing
system in place
and needs to avoid the situation
that we've seen over the weekend of
those crowds and crowds of people
at heathrow airport and that's happening
because the government does not have
this strategy in place i think by
putting in place that system
around hotels we've seen it work well in
australia for example
then that would be a step forward but i
come back to the central point
we can't keep moving chaotically
from one situation to another we need
that comprehensive system it needs to be
put in place
what about the restrictions that we've
got in place at the moment because
there's a lot of concern about the new
variant concern that it may be
and it is a may at the moment but it may
be more deadly we certainly know it's
more
transmissible the current lockdown rules
are
looser a little bit than they were in
the summit
does that need to change well look we
called for
a lockdown the government then for
england introduced that lockdown which
they
uh in my view had to do could we do
more yes of course we could do more
we've already been talking throughout
this interview
about the situation at the border and
i've indicated that that absolutely
needs to be tightened up
but there's also an issue around
messaging and the government getting its
messaging right
you know we had last summer for example
the so-called back to work message
trying to get people back
into the office and yet we're seeing
only in the last couple of days
in the government's own agencies take
the dvla in swansea here in wales from
where i'm
speaking to you where we've had an
outbreak in a workplace so we need
not only to make sure we get this
borders issue right which is absolutely
vital particularly for the strains that
are coming from abroad
but government messaging needs to be
more consistent and effective as well
can we just turn our attention to to the
state of the union because you've seen
the sunday times and that yougov poll
today look if as expected
the smp does as well in the elections in
may
as they're talking about they're on
about possibly getting a total of
70 seats which i think is more than half
of the number of seats in the
in the scottish parliament would that
give them a referendum a mandate for a
second referendum and would labor
support that
even if it didn't have westminster
approval
i think it would be a profound mistake
to take
the election of may in scotland or
indeed
any other part of the united kingdom for
granted and if any party
is taking votes for granted then they
clearly shouldn't be doing that we have
a very clear position going into those
elections in scotland
uh against the idea of a second
independence referendum and i
and it is and it is frustrating at the
moment i have to say because at the
moment
we are in the midst of this pandemic it
is this pandemic
and working together across the united
kingdom to try to
do our best to save life that should be
the absolute focus at the moment
not this constitutional issue okay nick
thomas simmons good to talk to you thank
you